Okay, I want to walk you
through another example.
This is a weight truck
app I built a while ago.
And I notice that when I open
the menu on the left hand side,
that it sticks and Janks.
Watch.
So now with the timeline open,
I'm going to see if I can
find out what the cause is.
The first thing I'm going to do
is refresh the page, just so
that I know I've got a fresh start.
Now what I'm going to do is, hit record.
Come over here and
bring out the menu and stop recording.
Immediately, I see that there
are three big spikes of yellow here.
So, I'm going to select one of those and
I realize that I am spending
a lot of time in JavaScript.
Once you zoomed in,
you can also get details of
what's going on in those frames.
Let me start by dragging this up
a little bit more, so we can see it.
You can see what it is,
how long it's been working,
when it started and a little bit
more about how it's broken down.
The time itself and any child records.
Lastly, you find out where the task
was triggered In your code.
The details will differ depending on
the kind of record you're looking at.
For example, recalculates dial,
tells you the number of elements
that were affected, as does layout.
With layout, we see the tree size,
the scope, where it started and
in this case,
we also see an additional warning.
Which we'll talk about in a little bit.
Lastly, we see where in
the code we triggered layout.
In this case though,
I would be most concerned about
these large yellow blocks.
They seem to be what's causing me
to stop hitting 60 frames a second.